[Música]
el Papa Francisco fue visto desde su
elección como un elemento renovador en
un estamento tan conservador como la
iglesia católica si bien Muchas veces
los cambios o no han tenido el calado
esperado se han visto frenados también
por corrientes más conservadoras el
pontífice ha tratado de dar pasos el
último de cara el próximo sínodo de
obispos un órgano que discute y que
aprueba las propuestas de la Reforma
dentro de la iglesia para presentárselas
al papa en este evento las mujeres
podrán votar por primera vez serán cinco
religiosas en total hasta ahora ellas
sólo tenían el papel de observadoras
vamos a conversar sobre este tema y para
ello la invitada es María José navasal
ella es doctora en historia y experta en
historia de la iglesia en Chile además
es secretaria ejecutiva de la sociedad
de historia de la iglesia chilena
Muchísimas gracias a usted por estar en
directo a América
Hola cómo estás Ángel un placer mire
desde el Vaticano se habla de una
renovación y no una Revolución en el
seno de la iglesia Usted cree que este
es un cambio real o es más bien una
modificación meramente estética para
contentar a las voces que piden mayor
inclusión de la mujer al final son solo
cinco religiosas
mira que lo planteé el papa ya es
importante sin embargo yo Considero que
solamente cosmético la mujer para la
jerarquía eclesiástica en la mayoría de
los casos ha sido un personal de
servicio no remunerado personas de
segunda clase y desechadas por una
estructura en la cual se acuerdan de
ella solamente cuando necesitan
conseguir algunos fines por lo que este
cambio de visión de la mujer en una
institución que ha sido guiada por
hombre es muy difícil y tiene gran gran
objeción esta renovación que se anuncia
Perdón ya la vimos y se planteó en
Vaticano segundo o sea llevamos 60 años
esperando Vaticano segundo realmente se
aplique y no habría algún cambio mayor
para ellos bueno Cómo ha sido recibida
esta noticia entre las capas más
conservadoras del Vaticano porque es que
además lo que se ha hecho históricamente
con la Iglesia Católica es reforzar un
papel de la mujer de completa sumisión
de completos sacrificio que está
aprobado hace daño a nuestra salud
mental hace daño a nuestros derechos
humanos
mira lo han recibido según lo que he
podido constatar de en estos días
pésimos O sea para una un ala
conservadora que es el ala fuerte que
tiene la Iglesia Católica especialmente
en el Vaticano les incomoda muchísimo
porque como bien planteaste tú la mujer
estaba para hacer sumisa No
necesariamente para tener voz tener
votos y dar a conocer en realidad Cuál
es su parecer que no siempre y la verdad
que la mayoría de las veces difiere con
las opiniones masculinas
Mira hay un dicho muy famoso Y es que
ninguna sociedad sale de adelante solo
con el 50% de su población Y eso mismo
va a suceder para la fe católica y para
las demás credos Usted cree que va a
sobrevivir la Iglesia Católica en el
tiempo claro es una institución
milenaria
pero cree que va a sobrevivir sin la
posibilidad por ejemplo de ordenar a
mujeres en la posición de sacerdotisas o
de curas
Mira yo creo que así como está hoy día
la Iglesia Católica está muriendo sola
sin mucha ayuda y el hecho de que hayan
mujeres sacerdotisas creo que va a
faltar mucho tiempo es un proceso mucho
más largo del que podríamos hacer
actualmente sin embargo el el papel de
diaconisas y de formación no solamente
de mujeres que son consagradas sino que
también mujeres que son laicas eh podría
ser un gran aporte a la iglesia ahora si
en el fondo el pensar que la
incorporación de la mujer bajo esta
mirada es para suplir las falencias
sacerdotes que hay en los templos se
puede dar un paso anterior y que no
necesariamente Aunque sí tiene directa
relación con las mujeres que en el fondo
aquellos hombres que dejaron la sotana Y
decidieron casarse porque se enamoraron
puedan tener la opción de volver en el
fondo a ejercer el sacerdocio como
casados y así los sacerdotes tienen la
posibilidad también de un apoyo femenino
al lado el apoyo femenino al lado dentro
del matrimonio es fundamental para la
estabilidad del ser humano Qué problema
hay en eso y mientras tanto caminamos
con la formación de mujeres para que
puedan ser diaconisas y en un futuro que
no Considero que sea muy próximo por
estas facciones extremadamente
conservadoras que tiene la Iglesia
Católica lleguen a ser sacerdotes
también bueno no hay más que caminar por
las calles de cualquier ciudad europea
para darse cuenta cuántas Iglesias se
han convertido con el paso de los años
en museos o en salones o para otro tipo
de eventos que nada tienen que ver con
la religión Simplemente porque no hay
fieles en América Latina digamos que el
caso es diferente no siendo un
continente de Gran corte católico sin
embargo también hay que ser justos no en
la lucha histórica de los derechos de
las mujeres son cientos y cientos de
años para que lentamente se hayan dado
cuotas de inclusión y pues esto nos ha
llevado al lugar donde estamos hoy Así
que pues sí habría que reconocer que
además de estas cinco religiosas hay
personas que no son obispos hay laicos
como usted lo decía con derecho a voto y
que se busca que haya cierta paridad en
la elección Es decir de todas maneras sí
habría que dar el visto bueno a que al
menos Aunque pequeños se haya dado este
pequeño espacio para personas que están
fuera de la cúpula del Vaticano
sí pero hay un problema ahí también si
bien es un está se está mostrando en el
fondo una buena voluntad frente a esto a
mí lo que me preocupa es que primero
efectivamente haya variedad porque una
cosa es que se busque la paridad y otra
cosa es que se cumple una paridad y lo
segundo es el clericalismo cuando
nosotros escogemos a 70 personas por con
pinzas y cinco religiosas y cinco
sacerdotes más que no son obispos con
pinzas precisamente para que siga por el
mismo camino que estamos hoy estaríamos
mal porque porque en el fondo no hay una
inclusión real crítica frente a la
situación de la iglesia hoy día y no
sería un aporte porque sería más de lo
mismo y esa No creo que la tenga
Solamente yo así que no que la tiene que
tener mucha más gente que está
preocupada primero que la institución no
muera que funcione Y que además en el
fondo se escuche a quienes son parte de
la iglesia Cuál es el grave problema que
hay hoy día cuando te dicen al laicado
es que usted la iglesia los necesita
perdón el laicado esa iglesia lo que
necesitan es la jerarquía lo que
necesitan es la Organización sacerdotal
que es la que guía la iglesia entonces
cuando ya tenemos ese mal entendimiento
de lo que es solamente el concepto de
iglesia estamos mal por lo tanto el
caminar No es la jerarquía sola porque
la jerarquía sola está muriendo lo que
necesita es un laicado activo pero que
tenga voz y voto frente a muchos
problemas que hoy existen en la
humanidad que hoy existen dentro de la
propia iglesia y que en el fondo no
están siendo escuchados porque porque la
jerarquía está más preocupada de
mantenerse en el estatus en el cual está
y no realmente acercarse a lo que ellos
mismos denominan el pueblo de Dios ya
para finalizar y no nos queda mucho
tiempo entonces por qué esa resistencia
tanto a decisiones que realmente son
minúsculas como incluir a cinco mujeres
en un sínodo hasta las demás decisiones
grandes que debería o algunos piensan Al
menos que debería tomar la iglesia en
términos de derechos sexuales y
reproductivos en términos de
participación de inversión en fin
mira aquí hay un tema grande Yo creo que
es un problema también meramente
histórico cuando nosotros sacamos a las
grandes mujeres que han sido
fundamentales en la iglesia donde se
quedan en Eva y en María Magdalena Eva
que fue la mujer que hizo que
Adán y el pecado Claro ya voy a entrar a
la Virgen María Eva que en el fondo hizo
que se equivocara Adán cuando tenía sus
propias decisiones y en el fondo es una
debilidad masculina tenemos a María
Magdalena que siempre se tildó como una
pésima mujer que estuvo al lado de él y
que como que siempre lo estuvo tentando
y bueno Y tenemos obviamente a la a la
figura mayor que es la Virgen María pero
que se muestra como madre sumisa
preocupada del otro siempre protegiendo
al hijo protegiendo la institución que
en este caso sería la familia y que
también se representa en la iglesia o
sea estamos hablando de que la figura
femeninas que han sido destacadas han
sido en un en una guía en el fondo para
que la mujer siga siendo esa mujer
sumisa que nunca lo ha sido ni siquiera
dentro de un matrimonio y que por lo
tanto es un cambio que no están
dispuestos a perder un terreno que por
lo general y siempre fue masculino
además inhumanamente casta y además muy
muy heteronormativa Muchísimas gracias
María José navasal doctora en historia
experta en historia de la iglesia en
Chile por sus aportes a esta
conversación que seguro seguirá durante
muchos años un placer Ángela y que estén
todos muy bien gracias También a
nuestros televidentes pero les pido que
se queden con nosotros pequeña pausa y
ya volvemos con más de directo a América
[Música]